Digamos que tengo el punto (3,-4), entonces eso
sería 1, 2, 3 y 4 hacia abajo, esto es (3,-4), y
también tengo el punto (6,1), 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,1,
aquí está el punto (6,1). En un video anterior
vimos que podemos usar el Teorema de Pitágoras
para calcular la distancia entre estos dos puntos,
simplemente dibujamos un triángulo allí y nos
dimos cuenta de que esta era de la hipotenusa.
En este video vamos a tratar de averiguar cuál
es la coordenada del punto que está exactamente
a medio camino entre este punto y este punto;
podemos imaginar la línea que los conecta como
la distancia entre ambos. Ahora bien, ¿cuál es
la coordenada del punto que está exactamente
en medio de estos dos puntos?, ¿cuál es esta
coordenada de aquí? Es algo coma algo, y para
hacer eso voy a dibujarlo más grande aquí, porque
creo que descubrirás que es bastante sencillo en
realidad. Al principio puede parecer un problema
realmente difícil. ¡Caray!, voy a usar la fórmula
de la distancia con algunas variables, pero verás
que en realidad es una de las cosas más sencillas
que aprenderás en álgebra y geometría. Digamos
que este es mi triángulo, este de aquí es el
punto (6,1), este aquí abajo es el punto (3,-4),
y estamos buscando el punto que está justo entre
estos dos. ¿Cuáles son sus coordenadas? Parece
muy difícil al principio, pero es fácil cuando
piensas solamente en términos de las coordenadas
x y y. ¿Cuál será la coordenada x de este punto?
Esta línea de aquí representa x = 6, esto de aquí
representa x = 6, esto de aquí representa x = 3.
¿Cuál será la coordenada x de este punto? Bueno,
su coordenada x va a estar justo entre las dos
coordenadas x, esto es x = 3, esto es x = 6, va
a estar justo en el medio esta distancia, será
igual a esa distancia, su coordenada x va a estar
justo entre el 3 y el 6. ¿Cómo llamamos al número
que está justo entre el 3 y el 6? Bueno, podríamos
llamarlo el punto medio o la media o el promedio
o como quieras llamarlo, sólo queremos saber cuál
es el promedio de 3 y 6; y para encontrar el punto
entre 3 y 6 simplemente hay que calcular 3 + 6 /
2, lo que es igual a 4.5, así que la coordenada x
va a ser 4.5. Voy a dibujar eso en la gráfica: 1,
2, 3, 4.5, y puedes ver que está justo a la mitad,
esa es su coordenada x. Ahora, siguiendo con la
misma lógica, la coordenada y de este punto va
a estar justo entre y = -4 y y = 1, así que va
a estar justo entre ellos, la coordenada y va a
estar entre y = -4 y y = 1, así que calculamos
el promedio: 1 + 4 negativo / 2 que es igual a
-3 / 2, o podemos decir -1.5, entonces bajamos,
1.5 está literalmente ahí. En resumen: calculas
el promedio de las x, luego calculas el promedio
de las yes, o tal vez debería decir la media para
ser un poco más específico, una media de sólo
dos puntos, el punto equidistante a ambos es el
punto medio de la recta que los conecta; entonces
las coordenadas son 4.5, 1.5 negativo. Hagamos un
par más de estos que verás son bastante sencillos,
pero voy a graficarlos para visualizarlos. Digamos
que tengo el punto (4, -5), entonces 1, 2, 3, 4,
y luego bajo 5: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, esto es (4,-5);
y tengo el punto (8,2), entonces 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8,2. ¿Cuáles son las coordenadas del punto
medio entre estos dos puntos, el punto que está
justo entre ellos? Bueno, calculemos el promedio
de los valores de las x y calculemos el promedio
de los valores de las yes, por lo que el punto
medio será los valores de x son 8 y 4, 8 + 4 / 2,
y el valor de y será: tenemos un 2 y un -5 por lo
que es 2 + -5 / 2. ¿A qué es igual esto? Esto
es 12 / 2 = 6, 2 - 5 = 3 negativo, 3 negativo
/ 2 es 1.5 negativo. Ahí está el punto medio,
literalmente sólo debes calcular el promedio de
las x y el promedio de las yes, o encontrar sus
medias. Vamos a graficarlos para asegurarnos de
que se vea como un punto medio: 6, -1.5, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6,-1.5, aquí está, sí, se ve bastante bien,
parece que es equidistante de este punto y de este
punto de arriba. En resumen, todo lo que tienes
que recordar es calcular el promedio o la media de
los valores de las x o la x que se encuentra entre
las otras dos, y haces lo mismo con los valores de
las yes, los promedios y con eso tienes el punto
medio. Lo que voy a mostrar ahora es algo que está
en muchos libros de texto: si tienes el punto (x₁,
y₁) y luego tienes el punto (x₂, y₂), muchos
libros te dan lo que se conoce como la fórmula
del punto medio, aunque a mí me parece que no vale
la pena memorizar, porque sólo hay que recordar
que hay que promediar y encontrar el punto medio
entre las x y las yes. Entonces la fórmula del
punto medio -aquí voy a inventar la notación-,
el punto medio de x y el punto medio de y serán
iguales a (x₁ + x₂ / 2, y₁ + y₂ / 2), y pareciera
que es algo que tienes que memorizar, pero sólo es
el promedio o la media de estos dos números: sumo
estos dos, dividido entre dos, sumo estos dos,
lo divido entre dos, y obtengo el punto medio.
A esto se refiere la fórmula del punto medio.